most people spend money on dumb things
which then forces them to do things they
don't want so step number one for most
people in here they should sell their
home take the money and go rent return
their BMW and get a Toyota I own a BMW
God damn it and honestly that becomes
the vulnerability why do you own a BMW
cuz I love the car just the brand and I
I love driving it so I don't know so to
me that's where it gets interesting
right do you or do you like what the
brand does to make you look to other
people I don't know I'm not assuming you
have a point you have a point I know I
have a point I don't know you but I know
in the macro that 98% of people that buy
a Mercedes or BMW likes what it makes
other people think of them not that they
like it and that
$487 a month versus what they really
need which is $100 a month is why they
have a job they hate because they're
paying for a life that means nothing